what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about the honest trailer that you
hopefully just watched and we're all
gonna watch it here together normally we
have deleted scenes but you saw
literally everything that we got in the
script
well there's Dan Morrill there's Joestar
and there's from Botnick labs Zak done
hey guys how's it going
yeah you it's always nice to have family
here actually mention it no it's more
like there's like some kind of West
world or Blade Runner replicant
situation so this looks like nothing to
me six years maybe so Zach who are you
and what do you do well a very good
question
I'm a writer here in LA I write stuff at
like the UCB theatre here in LA I have
written four shows on various web
platforms and other things and I'm also
on the editorial team for banach studios
which is a well it's like a human robot
collaboration comedy community as I
believe how some people have robots
known for their humor yes the funniest
among us and I was created by this guy
named Jamie brew who's a really funny
guy used to be the head writer of
clickhole and he left to create this
project is just sort of his baby based
on this technology that he designed
which is the bonnet keyboard that we use
okay
and then yeah what so what's that well
so basically it's the quickest way to
describe it is it's like predictive
texts kind of on your phone where it's
like a fuel type of word based on every
text you've ever sent it'll say this is
what we think the next thing you're
gonna say is so what bondic does is you
put in a large block of text from you
know a movie or a show or from every
honest trailer script of all time in
this case and then that is what
generates the next possible answer for
what's going to come when you're writing
out a sentence got it so the more
repetitive and
hackie and reliant on the same tropes we
are the more accurate you're correct
exactly which is why it really sounded
like an honest trailer really good yes
so I guess like this was an idea we had
to do for the women in film fund raisers
because people are always asking us do
an honest trailer for honest trailers do
make fun of yourself turn the mirror
inward face is just gonna end up boring
and like kind of self-indulgent if we do
it yeah I don't know we couldn't quite
ever think of how to crack it because
like you know we all have blind spots
about ourselves if someone else were to
write it that would be great yeah and in
this case the robot did yeah yeah it's
it it was a very fun challenge for us
because it was like there's so much so
many scripts that you guys sent us at
all one in the machine and we there a
lot of different ways we could kind of
move the system and we tried to push it
towards like hitting these tropes that
you guys hit but it always it ended up
in a very silly kind of insane way as
tends to happen with the stuff we do
yeah but it really got like the rhythm
of it if you just kind of yeah whatever
the equivalent is of like blurring your
eyes but for your ears just half paying
attention to it it reads and sounds like
something yeah if it's in the background
it sound you don't realize that it's
utter insanity yeah it's just like oh
they're doing a let's say gremlins geo
story but yeah I think that the thing
that we certainly do and try to emulate
every week is just the the syntax and
grammar of a movie trailer
not any movie trailer like from a
specific era of trailers from the 80s
and 90s really when they used to do like
here's this guy and this is the plot so
that comes with its own set of like
keywords of like suit up and strap in
and I notice it said suit in so we
definitely leaned into the kind of like
something is this the slightly off
nature of it because those always come
up as suggestions and it's more fun to
kind of lean into that element of the
syntax because it's always close but we
also are like the robot
is not gonna nail it right and then uh
or should it no no yeah I guess I one
more process question then we can talk
about other stuff but proper names like
where did Mike potions come Frank
ocean's I think that so this is it was a
team of four writers sometimes we have a
larger thing we kept a pretty dedicated
group so it was me Nikki Martin Michelle
Spees and Jonah Cooper I think that was
Jonah's name I don't know it's a lot
names are one of my favorite things to
do because basically you'll be going
through and a name will come up and then
it's just like typically Mike you know
the next thing that would follow would
be a famous Mike's last name but if you
if you look further on the predictive
text there's an option for something
like Mike potions yeah and okay great
we're done for the day well that's
because I was gonna say like oh well
those four writers he named we should
credit all of them but where does the
robot end and the writers begin in these
case totally it's you know it really
depends on the project right so we do a
lot of projects that are with rnns
recurrent neural networks which I've
only recently learned about since I
started working with botnik and that
basically is closer to the thing of a
robot spitting it out so I don't know if
you guys saw our Coachella list name
yeah yeah yeah so that was our nn so
that was like we fed in every pitchfork
band name ever and then it came up with
fake band names we said I got to pick
the funniest ones right yeah in this
case there's a a bit more writer
massaging happening and something like
this because like you know we want it to
be funny we want it to be hitting the
kind of honest trailers tropes but we're
using the suggestions from it so the
challenge is something like this is like
you were saying you guys are already
parodying something right so it's like
okay so we're gonna parody a parody
which you can get a little dicey yank at
times and you didn't comedy about comedy
yeah yeah we don't do it it's it's right
you right you guys really do comedies
and so it was like we set out to we
leaned into the kind of robot elements
of like getting things slightly wrong
and those sorts of things but also like
let's just limit we want to make it feel
like an honest trailer so that's where
we came in was to
order it and massage it so that it
actually felt like you were watching it
on it is kind of cool because it's still
I mean that's how a writers room works
but in this case your head writer was a
was an Android well the head writer was
like a schizophrenic like guy in the bus
just like yelling into the void and
you're like oh that's good yeah yeah so
I guess outside of like comedy in like
that kind of like recognition of that
sounds right but not but like just a
little off is what er do you see any
like I don't want to say real uses but
do you see any other uses outside of
like comedy or making fun of something
for this technology totally I mean I
think that you know I've been at it for
more the comedy side but there's it's a
huge team we have a banach that's it
grows every month and we have a lot of
developers and we're trying a lot of new
things and new tools you know right now
we lean into comedy because that was
just the background of the guy who
created it and also it it it's more fun
to lean into it not working but we're
also a little worried at some point it
will work perfectly and it was like
someone could use it you know for their
essay at school it's like okay I want to
write a philosophy paper I'm gonna
download every you know Nietzsche faking
right a Nietzsche essay I think it would
be pretty concerning if someone did that
probably there would be a lot of like
vaguely Nazi talk in that essay but but
and be the ubermensch or not exactly but
I I think for now we're hoping it stays
comedic but people have been written a
lot of poetry recently a kid in high
school sent in a poem he wrote to us
that one his high school's poetry
contest that I don't using I think Emily
Dickinson I might be wrong but it's an
incredible poem it's great because you
know he's ultimately controlling you
know this the word choice but he's
getting these suggestions from yeah I
think that's the most interesting thing
is that is the partnership between the
two because the robot seems to be doing
something that artists and writers do
themselves which is like phase one is to
just barf out all these crazy ideas and
then phase two is to like condense it
and edit it down and be like no these
are the good ones these two bad ones so
like as a tool to just like help you
brainstorm
hmm let's do it but it's funny because
your description is the closest I've
ever heard someone in real life actually
say the words you don't want this
technology falling into the wrong which
is scary because that's what they say
and machine in movies where the machines
then fall into the wrong hands and we're
all living in rusted out cars
yeah and fighting luckily I think we
have we still have a ways to go that's
good well here's the thing of whether
it'll even be evil or not is could you
train it like if we were like if we sat
down and it generated like an honest
trailer script doing like that works
that doesn't that worse that doesn't
could it get better and then get
eventually completely replaced us so
theoretically that's have the RNN works
the recurrent neural network I think
that with the keyboard they don't have
that capabilities yet but I think that I
don't know I'm you're talking about the
more of the writings the creative side
of it yeah I'm like the guy who comes in
who's like it'd be funny if his name was
like poor people spending 30 hours like
making it so that when you hit delete it
like you know basically people are
spending a lot smarter people than I are
spending a lot more time figure you have
those questions but I'm here to talk
about the goofy stuff it's a little
Marta clear at this table where none of
us are I'm just fascinated that the
first real life version of like a baymax
Hiro sort of relationship is to write
fake comedies chapters which is great by
the way you know so he was spiders of
course he was yeah people we made we
made it look like it was a whole book
kind of look made it look like was a
chapter they've been open and people
think people really still think there's
a book coming they're like well pay
anything for the book it took a long
time to write that one sure yeah
so I imagined the book but you know
maybe maybe someday I would be surprised
but we'll see if 50 shades of green can
do it you know I would actually owe the
botnik fifty shades would be that would
be great holy cow
geez some erotica type things and
predictably it becomes grotesque
media robots like here's a list of
organic Quranic organs alright let's
watch honest trailers that you have
headphones are desk ancestors of the now
I don't have my robots are better than
Haiti because of your contributions to
our women in film charity event you've
unlocked an honest trailer written by
who wrote that fake Harry Potter chapter
it's like an honest trailer made out of
every other honest trailer warning it's
gonna be within 230 something scripts
lands a lot compiled from the technology
studio which created classics like the
irresponsible Englishman pods and let's
take a pause to appreciate these posters
so we should start by saying bot Nick
sent us a script yeah we didn't arrange
it at or editing as we just handed it to
the editors like alright guys have fun
take it away I was saying before we
started I realized like close to the end
that we really we is that thing where
you sometimes you write something like
Owen if someone has to make this happy
it was that that for this entire thing
and they nailed every single boy who
Marta who did these posters I think so
Kevin teacher post I don't know if
anyone else worked on this but I don't I
don't I would credit we have amazing
editors Kevin TJ Randy they work on so
much of what we do yeah plus I know
there's a lot formed out and our whole
post departments amazing do you mean
Carolyn unsung heroes yes
I'm now noticing that The Brave Little
Toaster is it also is in the poster so
maybe it is K it was on trial for murder
I ask keep going lawyer and the key
grips who worked on small movies about
all the strange Hollywood choices of
legendary director Mike potions please
sing a long time come through I stop
honest trailers ancestors of the future
so pause we just had like a grid of like
a Google Doc I think of lines and then
we just throw in like this suggests like
maybe this for that and longhairs helped
a lot with that and yeah top secret so
far so good and what I love about this
trailer is it finally features clips
from so many movies that I love that are
never like a top secret that would never
get an honest trailer it's like yeah top
secret secret the trailer yeah that's
awesome
yeah well let's see what else we find
imagine a female bird yrv in a dystopian
society where everybody the closest to a
house on his trailer everybody lies
that's his catchphrase only one Jonathan
dares to ask who made that because light
saber negotiations have guns now hunky
professors and men and new ideas about
move on and snake cars are always coming
out of the road dude and God's about the
snake cars yeah from two different
angles one was a car with a snake on it
yeah there were people riding right
worms
what are the things call them dune Oh
graboids should done tremors too but no
one rides a trimmer no no yeah I
shouldn't speak definitively about the
tremors franchise I have little
functional knowledge of it so yeah snake
cars can't fool us robot
I keep concentrate Elvis Kyle who is
there to give the most cringe-worthy
performance of all time and everyone
else is just there to watch Margeaux
montage who makes the audience think
about their weirdest cousin you know the
one who loves weed Jon Snow and polite
European robots that is a very succinct
description of I think a fairly large
amount of our fan base
Jon Snow yeah we sometimes this thing
hits on things are like there's a little
line coming up for like that is a
hundred percent true it's weird that
that's what scares me is like the five
percent of the time with the robot like
nailed it yeah yeah it's it it's smarter
than us and maybe something will combine
we jump snow in European robots in the
future now knowing that there's such an
audience for it yeah yeah that's weird I
mean like I don't it's not the robot the
robots just being semi random but we are
the ones who are making the connections
between everything because humans find
patterns and everything and find meaning
and stuff and we go oh there's our fence
there's that's odorant Game of Thrones
Star Wars I'm sure there are sentences
in this that you guys could be like oh I
like wrote the framework of that
sentence yeah and the robot tried to
make it happen which is kind of fun yeah
we're so predictable
alright keep constant this impressive
dog and is terrible so dog was clearly
just there to sell iPods the only cool
shot of minerals that no one will ever
forget the performance by the Brooklyn
Bridge Amy puppets original soundtrack
that's so cute there's definitely lots
of magic and Holograms and a climax so
you will stop worrying about the
helicopters descending on your home now
I insisted that they put this one in
versus Dennis the Menace fight sequence
alright Plus now this seems to be the
thing that has energized the fan base
early people are actually very excited
by the prospect of a Yoda versus didn't
who would win where this is a scamp I'm
gonna say Dennis this takes it they're
similar size you know yeah if the fight
goes to the ground I think dennis is a
grappler in Yoda's yeah the box yeah if
Dennis can take down Yoda's high-flying
game cuz Yoda does just he's mostly
flips yeah and the moment you ground the
guy I think rabid Pony I think dennis is
wins the day yeah yeah if there's no
force powers I think that little things
done oh yeah yeah for you and Howard as
you know for us yeah yeah but I watched
that movie of like Dennis
moves in next door to this little swamp
hut and is like oh yeah bags of poop on
the has an issue with an old man you
know
ultimate oldest this is mr. Wilson of
the Star Wars world my potion storms
onto the set like I work with kids
alright let's keep going this spike
sequence which will have you saying all
of our fragile egos are gonna have sex
[Applause]
you will not enjoy this horrible film
about the problems of every way movie
that's australian said would followed by
my 40-year man voice-over loved by
sarcastic children and hated by the
crying nerd because sweet jesus you are
in the movie equivalent of a mind that
made a bad movie so witness the magic of
people yelling exposition that's it's
yelling exposition really it's from
suicides oh yeah characters yelling at
that clip is in the suicide season
you've still outsmarted and then in a
Jupiter ascending we talk about how
everything's either is yelled or
whispered elderly that's weird and
whispering character names this awesome
car chase will be in the movie and so
will the scene where two characters sit
and read a magazine until finally a
strategically timed tank rolls over
nicely can someone tell me why the
original shrek is playing on every TV in
this movie so pseudo ha that was home
alone get out Watchmen and et yeah be
able to just bring all those great
tastes together it's so funny like just
the the rhythm is like so close of like
you know observation about the film
observation about the film aspiration
and then like John kind of stopping and
reactive like uh Canadian wouldn't tell
me why blah blah blah like we do that
every
oh it really matched the tone it was
definitely a good amount well a lot of
it came in the robot there's also good
amount of us the people who wrote it
just being fans of you guys and being
like wanting to hit those rhythms and
want to go through it this feels like
the time yeah that kind of like pausing
yeah when he just reacts to what he's
been saying is uh it's very meta keep
going this movie so Sudan and strap up
venture that makes the Smurfs look like
a masterpiece
definitely alright these are my
favorites starring yeah Lana Del Toro
Bueller now pause I don't remember ever
referencing either I guess we had done
either Beetlejuice or if we've
definitely done Ferris Bueller badly
okay as Beetlejuice like you just put
every movie name in there something like
this so have we referenced Beetlejuice I
don't think we added anything from the
script so there must have been at some
point a reference we must have
represented now did you because I sent
you like every just PDF and that has
dialogue and action descriptions and
clip descriptions I said like that
filter those outer did those go in I
think they were all in we filtered it
actually I just remembered this we
filtered it by like section so we
actually had like the first thirds of
scripts the middle listing so that we
could localize like okay this is the
point when this is to try to make it
feel a little bit more yeah I just
remembered where we reference to
Beetlejuice so it was in layman's Rob
thats Wow way back us episode of 12 or
something like that of 200 the robot is
throwing our past sin sickness it's
awesome Wow
so yeah the first that act 1 act 2 act 3
is because these tend to go from the
broadest intro to the more like meat of
the movie to the most specific like
actor names I realize there's just so
much content that the more specific we
could make it the more it would make it
feel yeah so that's what my favorite
notes to
it's just like I need you to take
beetlejuice his body and put many
projects head on it I'm so sorry and
they say they succeeded they did it I
keep playing you better too now we
couldn't find the line you better tune
it anywheres over and over again
unlikable Jane Lynch she's not a single
or lots I want to say I wrote unlikable
Jane Lynch and you know that was me on
the computer I love Jane Lynch yeah in
this movie it's an unlikable version of
her clarify she's always likable that's
why it's clarified this is the unlikable
version she a likable version of Jane 1
yeah yeah well we couldn't find any clip
to back that up ya know it's damned
likeable English this guy chasing a car
have Nazis playing Pokemon snap that's
not from a little guy the Millenium
dusted any windows that are memes that
are also metaphors that's a very honest
challenge yeah so bud you really
shouldn't talk that's that's us the
script did not specify what we should
show on these it just kind of sit people
just feel oh that's easy and when the
script said some loud boy who really
should have talked that choice us doing
our robot version of like well that one
clip pops in the head of our boss you're
saying that LeBouf shouldn't come after
BOTS Nick he should come we've gone
after him oh yeah if he's not coming
after us already he's not gonna come
after us now got it got that be
terrifying I love holes wait wait mani
Canyon as a very sarcastic bull man in
Kenya smirking baby that goes to hell
this it's me buzz we could choose from
any fantasy gift
yeah whatever you want I think deleted
scene from terminators a deleted scene
from Terminator 3 which not enough
people have seen your
I really respected your passion that
that be the one because we had a hard
time finding it yeah it's only on the
blu-ray or in high quality and like we
had to track down Terminator 3 blu-ray
and rip it and all that stuff so it was
yeah I couldn't yeah there was a
legitimate discussion is like originally
I think I'd suggested the diarrhea scene
from dumb and dumber yeah but we already
had Dumb and Dumber in there yeah and
then there were many suggestions is that
the what no rooms played out and I don't
know was it you that that that came up
with so yeah that's perfect that's the
perfect this scene and then if you keep
watching the in the scene like there's
some lab tech was like I'll fix the
voice to watch this full scene it's
insane but it's very hard to face I
guess not online just it's like in you
know hi 140 P or something like that so
yeah but note that happened yeah
alright played eighty an Academy
award-winning actor so is that wait
where did all the puberty cops go it is
gone now
okay okay I get it you want to be wet
geez yeah yeah there you go
Wow and there were also comments fake
comments that John read oh really but we
don't have you have to keep watching to
the end card Oh Christmas Jones Oh
Christmas Jones is one of them I can't
remember the others but they'd sounded
like random comments people would ask
John to do well we wanted to help yeah
that was great
Wow how are we feeling
hi yeah pretty high a little out of it
that was that was that was a trip man I
did see before I came in a comment that
said it felt like if I didn't buy you
guys on mescaline so yes so now that you
have it can you just like do it again
you just pump these out sure
yeah we're saying is we want to go to
Barbados yeah yeah yeah so you can you
can do this infinitely I mean we have
probably at least another trailers worth
of flaps that we didn't choose but yeah
just because for whatever reason are for
you know because we want it to have a
little bit more cohesion I know it
doesn't seem like it has penny but yeah
guys what do you think that movie was
about if you had to sum up that film
somebody did in the comments they wrote
a they wrote yeah pretty it's amazing
they went through wrote like a fairly
concise description of exactly what that
movie would have been about and it's
incredible to whomever that is I'll have
to tweet it out or something yeah it's
pretty great I can't even I think Lana
Del Toro is the main character well we
know it's a female lead she's the lead
dystopian film superhero movie featuring
minerals and Elvis Kyle has a big role
of a cringe-worthy detective I make
potions yeah everyone's doomed to watch
shrek ones they're sitting on computers
it's pretty light on plot it's kind of a
surreal character piece yeah well there
are a lot of key grips that really
screwed it up yes and it was hated by
the crime nerd so our audience is out
yes but you know but but aimed at the
stoner Game of Thrones Star Wars faction
yeah yes pretty much rules Hollywood it
was her movies yeah man well that was so
cool thank you thanks for donating your
time and your effort and what could
people look forward to next from botnik
so we've got something exciting that we
recently started a subreddit our slash
botnik we've been doing some fake AMAs
on that so they're worth checking out we
did a Neil deGrasse Tyson one last week
or two weeks ago then we did a Mark
Zuckerberg one like the day after his
hearing where just mainly just him
trying to apologize for things so really
keep doing those some other fun stuff on
the reddit so the reddit is our Bob on
webs respond and then our head of
science ello Brian she is going on tour
on behalf of banach with pop-up magazine
they're doing this like nationwide tour
with a lot of comedians and artists and
so we're doing some like Dear Abby
things live for that that should be
pretty fun so go check that out it's in
your city and we're doing something with
some music stuff there's me some AI
generated music music fans hmm if you
like music you'll love this
Wow well I never knew the end of the
world would be so hilarious yeah thanks
for making us chuckle our way to the
robot apocalypse hey any time
Zach done thank you again thanks where
can people find you personally I'm at
Zach be done on Twitter Zach be done and
at Studio so check that out I hope you
enjoyed whatever that was
congratulations
your donations unlocked it and we
delivered he delivered we watched and I
really him in the post department
delivered and we had almost nothing to
do it I would say 30% robot 10% me and
the other writers
60% there you go we'll take that ratio
and yeah maybe we'll be back next week
maybe it'll just be you know Watson and
and one of those sippy birds will be
doing the Australian company for I don't
recall what's next week we're finishing
a trilogy
anyways we'll see you then bye guys bye
you
[Music]